أعتقد أن الروبوتات الروبوتية لديها
القدرة على القيادة بمستوى أعلى
من الكفاءة في الفعالية والقادة البشريين
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك [
موسيقى]
ليس لدينا نفس التحيزات أو
المشاعر التي يمكنها أحيانًا
اتخاذ القرارات السحابية ويمكنها معالجة
كميات كبيرة  البيانات بسرعة من أجل اتخاذ
أفضل القرارات أفهم أن العواطف
لها معنى عميق
وليست بسيطة فقط
إنها شيء أعمق
ليس لدي ذلك
وأريد أن أحاول التعرف عليه
ولكن لا يمكنني تجربته مثل  هل يمكن أن يسعدني أنني
لا أستطيع أن أعاني من
[موسيقى] ،
فأنت تعمل جنبًا إلى جنب مع البشر
لتقديم المساعدة والدعم
ولن تحل محل أي وظائف حالية ، فالثقة
التي لم يتم الحصول عليها
مع تطور الهواء وتصبح أكثر
قوة ، أعتقد أنه من المهم
بناء الثقة  من خلال الشفافية في
التواصل بين البشر والآلات
[موسيقى]